This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。你有帮助产生真正改变的愿望吗？拉西特学院，为你提供依赖与心理健康专业。掌握核心能力
essential to accompany and support the people confronted to the challenges. Construise a career enrichicent to service of the community francophone
去陪伴和支持那些面临挑战的人。为服务整个国家的法语社群
of all the country. Don't know the Swin'Alice in French, it's possible with the CIT. Visit CollageLac.C.
打造一段丰富多彩的职业生涯。在法语区不知道Swin'Alice？通过CIT就能实现。访问CollageLac.C。
D.M.C. a initiative of the chief of the Consortium National of Formation in Health, supported by Santa Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up.
D.M.C.是国家健康培训联合会（Consortium National of Formation in Health）负责人的倡议，得到了加拿大圣安（Santa Canada）的支持。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓得要死。恶魔，醒醒。
I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive.
我是那个看到克雷维特（Crevette）和德皮波（DePippo）实施谋杀的女人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出一丝悔意，在被判处最高刑期后显得若无其事。我说，我没有罪。我要把这事告到怨情处。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷》中的“恶魔采石场”。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。
But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe is presented by CVS.
但现在，有一种全新且令人兴奋的方式来开启你走向更快乐生活的人生地图。Joy 101。这是一个全新播客，由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotb）主持。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋和感人的直播聊天。打开你的免费IHeart电台应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈现的由霍达·科特比主持的《Joy 101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive.
每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发、真实和真诚的，只是关于生存意义的坦诚对话。
I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier El Chicharito Hernandez），请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。难道所有人都在对我说谎，隐瞒他们是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我不得不做的事。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深层卧底：顾家男人》。
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for an episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, let's talk about something I think many of us believe we are doing, but probably aren't doing very well, which is processing our emotions. This is something that I've come to find. If you are a very self-aware, smart individual of whom I know many of you are, and you cry occasionally and you get sad occasionally and you're happy occasionally and you have every word under the sun to explain what it is your feeling and why.
大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Spike），欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天，让我们来谈谈一件我认为我们许多人都觉得自己正在做，但可能并没有做好的事情，那就是处理我们的情绪。这是我渐渐发现的一件事。如果你是一个非常有自我觉察、聪明的人（我知道你们当中有很多人都是这样），而且你偶尔会哭，偶尔会难过，偶尔会开心，并且你能用世上所有的词汇来解释你的感受是什么以及为什么会有这种感受。
You probably believe that you are someone who processes your emotions well, or who finds that their emotions have a very nice, like, beginning, middle, and end. You definitely see yourself as somebody who is very emotionally adjusted. Maybe you are. But I'm very guilty of this. Just knowing the words for your emotions. Or just knowing how you think you should be feeling and knowing why you should feel that isn't the same as A, actually allowing yourself to feel those emotions fully, even in their
你可能觉得自己是一个很擅长处理情绪的人，或者觉得自己的情绪有一个非常美好的开始、经过和结局。你绝对认为自己是一个心理调节能力很好的人。也许你确实是。但我对这一点非常内疚。仅仅知道形容情绪的词汇，或者仅仅知道你认为自己应该有什么样的感觉、以及为什么你应该有这种感觉，并不等于A，真正让自己充分体验那些情绪，哪怕它们处于
ugliest form, and B, is not the same as being able to move through those emotions and move through the discomfort. I think more and more of us, thanks to social media, thanks to just the reduction of stigma, thanks to just education. Like, we have the language for our motions without actually having the tools and without actually being able to fully express them. That's meaning we're still kind of feeling emotionally stunted even though we're very informed. That means that without realizing it, we can become somebody who can't connect with their emotions in a deep way, who can't connect with their emotions without feeling debilitated by them, even though we feel like we should and we do have a good hand over what we're feeling.
最丑陋的形式，并且B，这不等于能够穿越这些情绪并穿过这种不适感。我认为，由于社交媒体的普及、污名化的减少以及教育的普及，我们越来越多的人拥有了描述情绪的语言，却没有真正掌握工具，也无法完全表达它们。这意味着尽管我们见多识广，但在情感上我们仍然有些发育不良。这意味着在不知不觉中，我们可能会变成这样的人：无法与自己的情绪进行深层连接，无法在不被情绪击垮的情况下与情绪连接，尽管我们觉得自己应该掌控情绪，而且也确实对自己的感受有很好的掌控力。
So that is what we're going to break down today. Kind of a guide to the research on why and how we avoid a. emotions without consciously realizing it, what that actually looks like in our behavior and in our reactions to things. And some of the greatest tools and studies on what to actually do. Like, what does it mean to process an emotion? What does it mean to be able to cry when you want to cry? Sing and experience joy when you want to experience joy, be disappointed when you want to be disappointed. And I guess, like, really just exploring why that's actually a gift and we shouldn't be afraid to process emotions in a way that maybe is a little bit ugly and I guess how we do that
所以这就是我们今天要剖析的内容。这是一份关于以下内容的心理学研究指南：我们为什么以及如何在不知不觉中逃避情绪；这在我们的行为和对事情的反应中到底是什么样的；以及关于具体该怎么做的最棒的一些工具和研究。比如，处理情绪意味着什么？能够在想哭的时候哭出来意味着什么？在想体验快乐时歌唱并体验快乐，在想失望时感到失望意味着什么？我想，真的就是去探索为什么这其实是一份礼物，我们不应该害怕以一种可能有点丑陋的方式去处理情绪，以及我想我们是如何做到这一点的。
in the first place. So without further ado, let's get into how to actually process your emotions. To begin with, how can we identify when we are becoming detached from our emotions? And how can we identify when we are not processing our emotions in a sustainable way? Because I think sometimes it's not that obvious, right? When we're attached, or I'm sorry, detached from our emotions, though, I think things just feel flat. Like, we don't feel sad, we also don't feel happy. I've sometimes, like, heard this described as like, the world is a little bit, it's fuzzy, right? You don't seem to feel your pain in its fullest form, but you also don't feel your happiness in its fullest form either. You're like existing in the middle frequency of your feelings. Sometimes we're very
废话不多说，让我们进入如何真正处理情绪的话题。首先，我们如何识别自己何时开始与情绪脱节？我们又如何识别自己何时没有以一种可持续的方式处理情绪？因为我认为有时候这并不那么明显，对吧？然而，当我们与情绪脱节时，或者，抱歉，当我们与情绪脱节时，我认为事情感觉就是平淡的。比如，我们感觉不到悲伤，但也感觉不到快乐。我有时听到有人这样形容，世界变得有点，变得模糊了，对吧？你似乎无法最完整地感受到你的痛苦，但你也无法最完整地感受到你的快乐。你就像是存在于你各种感觉的中间频率中。有时我们非常
aware that this is the case. And sometimes, like, I don't want to say we enjoy it, but I don't know, we rely on it or we just don't have the capacity to fix this numbness. Like, after you've been through a big breakup or you've lost your job or you've had a really traumatic incident, you probably know you should be feeling things on a deeper level. You know you should be grieving or anxious, but it is like this emergency part of your body switches off and you don't necessarily know whether it would be better to switch it back on again. People can last like years in the state of numbness. Even after the original situation is like well in the past, even after the thing is like
清楚这一点。有时，我不想说我们喜欢这样，但不知道为什么，我们依赖于它，或者我们只是没有能力修复这种麻木感。比如，在你经历了一场重大分手、失业或经历了真正创伤性的事件之后，你可能知道自己应该在更深层面上去感受事情。你知道自己应该悲伤或焦虑，但就像你身体里负责紧急情况的部分关闭了，你未必知道重新打开它是否会更好。人们在这种麻木的状态中可以持续好几年。即使原来的情况已经过去很久，即使事情已经
even if it looks like they've eerily been coping all along, what's actually happening is that the emotions are like, they're still sitting in the emotional waiting room. They are yet to be processed and they need to be processed to be moved out of that waiting room. So why are we so bad at feeling our feelings? Obviously, there's a few very clear reasons. The biggest one being that processing our emotions in a helpful way was probably something that was never modeled to us as children or at any stage really by society, by our parents, by anybody. And so we don't have a guide on how to feel our emotions without them completely
甚至即使看起来他们一路上都在不可思议地应付过去，但实际上发生的情况是，情绪就像是它们仍然坐在情感候诊室里。它们尚未得到处理，必须经过处理才能被请出那个候诊室。那么，为什么我们这么不善于去感受自己的情绪呢？显然，有几个非常明确的原因。最主要的原因是，以一种有帮助的方式处理情绪，可能从来都不是我们在小时候，或者在任何阶段，由社会、由父母、由任何人向我们展示过的模范行为。因此，我们没有关于如何在不被情绪完全压倒的情况下感受情绪的指南。
overwhelming us. There's this, well, there was this really huge paper from like, I don't know, 2010 that showed, especially if you have emotionally stunted parents in particular, this reduces how many different emotions people report being able to label or feel. And it's highly correlated to emotional suppression in individuals themselves. So people, you know, couldn't name as many emotions as they actually had available to them. Contrary to popular belief, emotions are also not things that we're born understanding. We have to form a relationship to our emotions, and that is done by modeling the people around us and seeing what they're doing. If emotions aren't shown, unless they are this extreme thing, we don't actually get those skills. And if they, again, are only shown at their
这是一个，好吧，大约在2010年左右有一篇非常庞大的论文表明，特别是如果你的父母在情感上特别不够成熟，这会减少人们能够标记或感受到的不同情绪的数量。这与个人自身的情感压抑高度相关。所以人们，你知道，无法说出他们实际拥有的那么多情绪。与大众的看法相反，情绪也不是我们生来就能理解的东西。我们必须与自己的情绪建立关系，这是通过模仿周围的人并观察他们在做什么来完成的。如果不展示情绪，除非这是那种极端的事情，否则我们实际上无法获得这些技能。而且，如果它们再次仅在
highest, most intense level that also drives us to be a bit more avoidant of our emotions because our impression is that the only way to feel our feelings is intensely and is maybe violently or is severely. There is no moderation. Somebody's going to get hurt and so we don't feel them at all. Another reason, we are bad at feeling our feelings because it feels like self-protection. if we don't feel sad about what happened, you know, who's to say it happened at all? If we don't let ourselves feel angry, like, then maybe the emotional impact of what we've been through will just fade away. Like, ignorance is bliss.
最高、最强烈的水平上表现出来，这也促使我们对情绪更加回避，因为我们的印象是，感受情绪的唯一方式就是强烈地、甚至可能是剧烈地或严重地去感受。没有适度。会有人受伤，所以我们根本不去感受。另一个原因，我们不善于感受情绪，是因为这感觉像是一种自我保护。如果我们不对发生的事情感到难过，你知道，谁又能说它真的发生过呢？如果我们不允许自己感到愤怒，那么，我们所经历的事情在情感上的影响可能就会逐渐消失。这就叫“难得糊涂”。
That's kind of the mindset that we have unconsciously. The longer we avoid the emotional consequences, though, the longer we avoid, you know, the longer we avoid the origin point and we prevent ourselves from examining it, there's so much research that does also show that this isn't, again, this isn't a conscious thing. Sometimes our minds will unconsciously blunt or numb our emotions for us so that we can endure hard situations and so that our immediate survival isn't compromised by the intensity of our sadness or the intensity of our grief, our outrage, our loneliness, and the irrationality of those emotions sometimes, the fact that they cause us to sometimes do things we don't want
这就是我们潜意识里的心态。然而，我们逃避情感后果的时间越长，我们就越是在逃避，你知道，我们逃避原点的时间越长，并且阻止自己去审视它。大量的研究确实也表明，这并不是，再次强调，这不是一件有意识的事情。有时我们的头脑会无意识地削弱或麻木我们的情绪，以便我们能够忍受艰难的局面，这样我们的即时生存就不会因为悲伤的强度或悲伤、愤怒、孤独的强度以及这些情绪有时具有的不合理性而受到损害，因为它们有时会促使我们去做我们不想做的事。
do. The issue is that off switch isn't selective. It's very rudimentary. It doesn't just shut down what our brain sees as compromising or bad emotions. It's just going to shut down everything, meaning that all those positive feelings we still very much want to feel get dialed down, get diluted for us also because our mind is preventing us from feeling the bad feelings. The good feelings come along with it. When something difficult or traumatic happens or when numerous really frustrating hard situations occur all at once, our nervous system is basically just like an overwhelmed worker. Like it just can't cope. There's this amazing book called The Inner World of Trauma and the author of that book describes this phenomena very, very well where he says, we are all given more
问题在于，那个关闭开关不是选择性的。它是非常粗糙的。它不仅会关闭我们的大脑认为会带来麻烦或糟糕的情绪。它会关闭一切，这意味着我们仍然非常想感受的所有积极情绪也会被调低，为我们所稀释，因为我们的大脑在阻止我们感受糟糕的情绪。美好的感觉也随之而去了。当困难或创伤性的事情发生时，或者当许多非常令人沮丧的艰难情况同时发生时，我们的神经系统基本上就像一个不堪重负的工人。就像它根本应付不过来。有一本很棒的书叫《创伤的内在世界》，那本书的作者把这种现象描述得非常好，他说，生活中赋予我们的体验，
to experience in life than we can experience consciously. So like our brain cannot fathom everything that we have to go through. Emotional numbing is one of the ways that our brain, our minds have adapted to endure it. Remember, your brain, your mind doesn't care if you are fulfilled. Like at a fundamental level, it doesn't care if you are happy, it doesn't care if you are in touch with your emotions, it just cares that you are alive. And if that means shutting down the emotional centers of the brain, so be it. Even if that means we don't process things fully or we never process the middle and they linger. I think a lesser explored explanation as well is that we can also become emotionally numb and have this part of our brain shut off due to vicarious suffering and vicarious exposure to stressful and harmful things.
比我们有意识能体验到的要多得多。所以，就像我们的大脑无法参透我们所经历的一切一样。情感麻木是我们的大脑、我们的心智为了忍受这一切而适应的方式之一。记住，你的大脑、你的心智并不在乎你是否感到充实。从根本上讲，它不在乎你是否快乐，它不在乎你是否与自己的情绪保持联系，它只在乎你是否活着。如果这意味着关闭大脑的情感中心，那就这样吧。即使这意味着我们无法充分处理事情，或者我们永远无法处理事情的中段，任由它们挥之不去。我认为另一个探讨较少的解释是，由于替代性痛苦以及对压力和有害事物的替代性接触，我们也可能会变得情感麻木，并使大脑的这一部分关闭。
Yes, we may be enduring hard things in our lives. Our relationship isn't working the way we want it to. Our parents are getting older. Our jobs suck. We don't make enough money. At the same time as all of that personal stuff is going on, we're also being exposed to so much just like everyday suffering in the world beyond ourselves and so much daily stress about the future of the world that our individual issues become less of a priority and we're not able to focus on them because we have been emotionally desensitized. Think of it this way. I don't know, if you lived in like a, if you lived in an isolated island and you had been for the
是的，我们可能正在忍受生活中的艰难时期。我们的关系没有按我们希望的那样发展。我们的父母老了。我们的工作糟糕透顶。我们赚的钱不够。在处理所有这些个人事情的同时，我们还暴露在超越自身的广阔世界中如此之多的日常痛苦之中，以及对世界未来的如此多的日常压力之中，以至于我们的个人问题不再是优先事项，我们无法集中精力去处理它们，因为我们在情感上已经变得麻木了。可以这样想。我不知道，如果你住在一个，如果你住在偏远的小岛上，并且已经这样生活了
last 10 years and you suddenly came back to life right now and reality right now and society right now, you would freak out. You would think, oh my gosh, the world has gone to shit. Like it is an awful place to be being somewhat desensitized to that is our brain's way of trying to keep us calm in the face of just like an onslaught of negative information that would other. otherwise emotionally paralyzed us and maybe cause us to do irrational things. And that then bleeds into our personal lives. There is this really fascinating study they did, I think, like over a decade ago now in Canada. Canada, the US, I can't remember, where they exposed 60 men and women to read either negative news
过去10年，而你现在突然回到了现实生活和现在的社会中，你会抓狂的。你会想，哦天哪，世界已经变成一团糟了。这简直是个糟糕透顶的地方。对这一切保持一定的麻木，是我们的大脑试图让我们在面对铺天盖地、否则会在情感上让我们瘫痪并可能导致我们做出不理智行为的负面信息时保持冷静的一种方式。然后这会蔓延到我们的个人生活中。有一个非常迷人的研究，我想，大概是十多年前在加拿大做的。加拿大，美国，我记不清了，他们让60名男女阅读负面新闻
stories or neutral news stories. And then they measured their cortisol levels. The cortisol levels of these individuals didn't just. that significantly when they read the paper. But when they then exposed them to a personal stressor afterwards, that is when the people who had been exposed to the negative news story, that's when their stress response was revealed to be much, much larger compared to those who read the neutral stories. Essentially, like, the story may not have stressed them out, but it definitely lowered their ability to deal with their daily lives. And we know the more stressed you are,
报道或中性新闻报道。然后他们测量了他们的皮质醇水平。这些个人的皮质醇水平并没有因为他们读报纸而发生显著变化。但当他们随后让他们接触个人压力源时，那些接触过负面新闻报道的人，这时他们的压力反应被证明要比那些阅读中性报道的人大得多、大得多。本质上，就像，这篇报道可能没有给他们带来压力，但它绝对降低了他们应对日常生活的能力。我们知道，你压力越大，
the less connected you are with your emotions. The very environment we are in right now, you and me, like the chaos that we are enduring as a society, that does impact your personal ability to feel sad, to feel happy, to feel anything at all, because your cognitive resources are already taken up with so much other stuff happening around you. When it comes to emotional suppression, though,
你与情绪的联系就越少。我们现在所处的环境，你和我，就像我们作为一个社会正在忍受的混乱，这确实会影响你个人悲伤、快乐或感受任何事情的能力，因为你的认知资源已经被周围发生的其他大量事情占用了。然而，当谈到情感压抑时，
because that's really what we're talking about, there's actually two levels going on, right? this level we've just been talking about is often very unconscious, like the nervous system jumps in, shuts everything down, like goes to town, just leveling down our emotions, making us numb. The second level, though, is when we actually employ very often specific deliberate coping mechanisms to shut down our emotions for us. The first level, like no emotions are getting through at all. The second level, emotions are getting through, but then we're fielding these emotions are using these certain methods or coping mechanisms? So we've talked about the first kind,
因为这才是我们真正要谈论的内容，实际上存在着两个层面的情况，对吧？我们刚刚谈到的这个层面往往是非常无意识的，就像神经系统介入，关闭一切，就像疯狂运转一样，把我们的情绪降级，让我们麻木。然而，第二个层面是，当我们实际上经常采用非常具体的刻意应对机制来为我们关闭情绪时。第一个层面，没有任何情绪能通过。第二个层面，情绪可以通过，但随后我们正在处理这些情绪，正在使用这些特定的方法或应对机制？所以我们讨论了第一种，
but what are these underlying methods that we use in the second level of emotional suppression? You are, you definitely are probably familiar with a lot of these. And I think the biggest one that I think of for a lot of smart 20-somethings, like what we find ourselves doing is over-intellectualizing. If you are a smart person, you are so used to being able to outthink or outsmart any problem in your life that you apply the same behavior to your feelings. Intellectualizing, this is essentially we are trying to reason our way through what we're feeling in order to make those emotions more manageable. And I read this wonderful Psychology Today article that basically said, by channeling our emotions towards logic and reason and assessment, we make what is deeply personal a lot more abstract. Like we kind of get to remain at arm's length from it without actually feeling the hard
但是我们在情感压抑的第二个层面中使用的这些潜在方法是什么？你肯定对其中很多都很熟悉。我认为对于许多聪明的二十多岁年轻人来说，我想到的最大的一点，就是我们发现自己在过度理智化。如果你是一个聪明人，你已经习惯了能够用智谋战胜或智胜生活中的任何问题，以至于你把同样的这种行为应用到了你的感觉上。理智化，这本质上是我们试图通过推理来度过我们的感受，以便使这些情绪更容易管理。我读过一篇非常棒的《今日心理学》（Psychology Today）文章，它基本上说，通过将我们的情绪引导向逻辑、理智和评估，我们把非常个人的东西变得更加抽象。就像我们得以与它保持一臂之隔，而无需真正去感受其中艰难的部分，
parts of it because it's something that we understand theoretically and therefore we don't have to understand emotionally. You know, if you're deeply hurt by a relationship breakdown, if you're really terrified of being single, if you're struggling with heartbreak, instead of letting yourself be sad, if you throw yourself into analyzing emotional attachment styles and reading self-help books and like micro-analizing every single thing, like in a very systematic way, that means you don't actually have to feel how sad you are. Another example is like if you're somebody who's been hurt deeply by like your parents' past behavior and their unkindness and their cruelty,
因为它是一件我们从理论上理解的事情，因此我们不必从情感上去理解。你知道，如果你被关系的破裂深深伤害，如果你真的很害怕单身，如果你正在与心碎作斗争，而不是让自己去悲伤，如果你投身于分析情感依恋风格、阅读自助书并以一种非常系统化的方式微观分析每一件事，这意味着你实际上不必去感受到底有多难过。另一个例子是，如果你是一个被父母过去的行为、他们的不友善和残酷深深伤害的人，
using language that describes their behavior and the psychological family models that they're operating in and, you know, all the different science, but never actually using any language to describe how you feel or how you felt. That is intellectualizing. You know, if you're going through grief, you could tell me the five stages of grief. You could tell me the biology of grief, the psychology of loss, but that's not the same as feeling what you are actually going through. the thing is that like knowing and having the words for it sounds a lot like processing but it's at this emotionally distant level where like we are adding a layer and layer of rational explanation onto an emotional wound we're wrapping it up in this like cellophane or in this like bubble wrap
使用描述他们行为的语言、他们所运作的心理家庭模型，以及各种科学，但从不使用任何语言来描述你的感受或你的曾经感受。这就是理智化。你知道，如果你正在经历悲伤，你可以告诉我悲伤的五个阶段。你可以告诉我悲伤的生物学、失落的心理学，但这并不等于去感受你实际正在经历的事情。问题在于，了解这些并拥有描述它们的词汇听起来很像是在处理情绪，但它处于这种情感疏离的层面，就像我们在情感伤口上添加了一层又一层的理性解释，我们把它用这种玻璃纸或这种气泡膜包裹起来，
so that we don't actually have to feel the raw feeling the other thing about this is it just like it just doesn't work. Like, we have evidence to show that intellectualizing in the long term doesn't work. Specifically, some studies in the early 2000s that looked at hundreds of participants and essentially found that people who, like, have the academic or intellectual words for how they feel may not necessarily adjust better than people who don't. Because the people who don't often just have to sit with the feeling, they can't explain it away. This is something I've heard.
这样我们就不必去感受那种原始的感觉。关于这一点的另一件事是，它就是，它就是不管用。就像，我们有证据表明，长期来看，理智化是行不通的。具体来说，2000年代初的一些研究观察了数百名参与者，基本上发现那些对自己的感受有学术或理智词汇的人，其调整得未必比那些没有这些词汇的人更好。因为那些没有的人通常只能去体会这种感觉，他们无法用逻辑解释过去。这是我听说过的。
I've actually spoken to a lot of my friends who are psychologists about this. And they struggle with this with their patients, right? Like they have a patient come in who is probably a lot like you, very, very smart, very curious. You're listening to this podcast. Like, you know, you really want to know answers for yourself. You've maybe experienced real hurt, betrayal, rejection. And you have this language for why this person did what they did. You understand that psychology behind why they reacted the way they did.
实际上我跟很多身兼心理学家的朋友聊过这个。他们在面对病人时也很纠结，对吧？比如来了一个病人，可能很像你，非常非常聪明，非常好奇。你正在听这个播客。就像，你知道，你真的很想为自己找到答案。你可能经历过真正的伤害、背叛、拒绝。你拥有了解释这个人为什么会做他们所做之事的语言。
But now you almost like, my friends say, like, I almost have to do the reverse. I can't just give the explanation. I have to almost take the explanation away from these people and just be like, just sit with it. Like, you don't need the complex words, just feel. So that's the first way, intellectualizing. Another way we avoid processing our emotions is through escapism, which just like intellectualism is complicated at times because it's so socially acceptable. Like, it is really socially acceptable to go out and get drunk after losing your job and maybe, you know, the next day and the next day because like, why the hell not?
但现在你几乎，我的朋友们说，我几乎不得不反其道而行之。我不能只给出解释。我几乎不得不把这些人的解释拿走，然后说，就去体会它。你不需要复杂的词汇，去感受就行了。这就是第一种方式，理智化。我们避免处理情绪的另一种方式是通过逃避，这和理智化一样，有时很复杂，因为它是如此被社会接受。比如，失业后出去喝得烂醉是非常被社会接受的，也许，你知道，第二天和接下来的每一天都这样，因为，为什么不呢？
Like, you're unemployed. It is super socially acceptable to binge watch a TV show instead of going out with your friends or to always have a TV show playing in the background so you don't have to listen to your thoughts. You know, it's socially acceptable just to give one more example to become obsessed with loving or even hating a particular celebrity. becoming obsessed with a particular book series of video game, with going to the gym after you've gone through something hard or just on a regular basis. Escapism, like the psychological definition, is essentially when we divert our attention away from internal discomfort by immersing ourselves in an outside situation that feels a lot safer and easier to control and to understand.
你失业了。疯狂追剧而不是和朋友出去，或者总是让电视在背景里播放，这样你就不用听自己的想法，这超级被社会接受。你知道，再举一个例子，对喜欢甚至讨厌某个特定名人变得痴迷，这也是被社会接受的。对某个特定图书系列或电子游戏变得痴迷，在经历艰难的事情后或定期去健身房。逃避，从心理学定义上讲，本质上是我们通过沉浸在一个感觉安全得多、更容易控制和理解的外部情况中，来将注意力从内在不适中转移开。
I feel like hating celebrities is a great example of this. it is not only obviously a distraction, it is a way in which we get to feel like we're controlling somebody else's life or we have a say or we have some kind of authority over them when during and within our own lives, we don't have any authority. We feel the complete opposite. We feel completely out of control. There's one like massive form of escapism though that we need to discuss.
我觉得讨厌名人就是一个很好的例子。这不仅显然是一种分散注意力的方式，也是一种让我们觉得自己在控制别人的生活，或者我们有发言权，或者我们对他们拥有某种权威的方式，而在我们自己的生活期间和内部，我们没有任何权威。我们感觉恰恰相反。我们感觉完全失去了控制。不过，有一种大规模的逃避形式是我们不得不讨论的。
Like it's probably the one that you are going to relate to the most. We're going to take a short break. See if you can guess it. We'll be right back. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCity, you offer the program
就像这可能是你最能感同身受的那种。我们将进行短暂的休息。看看你能不能猜出来。我们马上回来。你有帮助产生真正改变的愿望吗？拉西特学院，为你提供项目
Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the safety mental and of dependence. Construise a career
依赖与心理健康。掌握伴随和支持面临心理安全和依赖挑战的人所需的
enriching to service of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the Soin' Concibly in French, it's possible with the city. Visit the College
核心能力。打造一段服务于全国法语社群的
LaCite point CA, right now. An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Sancter Canada
丰富职业生涯。在法语中不知道Swin'Concibly？通过城市（city）就能实现。现在就访问LaCite学院点CA。由加拿大健康培训国家联合会发起的倡议
in the moment it felt like it was going on forever I didn't think I was going to live, I was terrified
那一刻感觉好像永无止境，我以为我活不成了，我吓坏了
there was no anything inside those eyes they turned black it's scared the hell out of me that was your first
那些眼睛里没有任何东西，它们变得漆黑，这把我吓得要死那是你的第一个
murder case yes sir fear to say this was the biggest case of your career yes sir rape a murder of a child
谋杀案吗？是的，长官，可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官，强奸并谋杀儿童
just as bad as it gets I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse,
能有多糟就有多糟，我想是的。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个看到谋杀案由克雷维特和德皮波实施的女人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出一丝悔意，
appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在被判处最高刑期后显得若无其事。我说，我没有罪。我要把这事告到怨情处。在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔的采石场》。
And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, Subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
要在Apple Podcasts上免广告并收听独家内容来收听《恶魔的采石场》，请订阅Apple Podcasts上的Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，比如当演员奥利维娅·芒（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我患过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌，那更困难。
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kofi, be on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's a part of a surprise to me because their new star is Javier T-Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我根本没有为主产后焦虑做好准备。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听由霍达·科特比主持的《Joy 101》。这对我来说有点惊喜，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。我仍然有这么多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza. From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine.
你如何应对取消文化？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨。从日常与平凡到深邃与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发、真实和真诚的。
This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait, me, I'm going to be able to be
这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一场深度交谈，脆弱感流露出来。阴谋论摆上台面，目标和人生教训得以分享。这世间的一切都有完美的秩序，一切皆是公正。等等，我，我将能够
going to be able to connect. The Chicharito. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. And together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, Extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac.
能够连接。小豌豆。我们在这里连接。小豌豆。我们将与IHeart Radio一起，将平凡变得非凡。敬请期待。这是一个。
Listen to learning to be human on IHad Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are?
请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们将与文化中最热门的人物对话，比如斯韦·李（Sway Lee）。你意识到自己有多传奇吗？
I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we gotta be going. Yeah. That's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy.
我很感激。我看到了，但我想，天哪，我还有，比如，更多的事情要做。就像王子（Prince），他发行了，比如30张专辑。我们现在才发行了，比如五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。是的。这态度真好。你还会听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先驱的故事，比如法布·5·弗雷迪（Fab Five Freddy）。
I directed when the Nas' early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. Yes. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nas was just beginning to take off.
我导演了纳斯（Nas）早期的视频之一。哪一个？《One love》。哇。是的。我真的在他的皇后桥（Queensbridge）公寓里拍的。他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。纳斯才刚刚开始崭露头角。
His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chance brings you. you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. A huge form of escapism that I think we are all waking up to, and which I know is my coping mechanism for sure is overworking.
他老爸以前住在哈林区（Harlem）我附近。他爸爸带他接触了大量的，你知道的，有觉悟的东西，他造就了一个年轻的神童。无论哪个时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来。为你带来最大牌的人物和最无过滤的对话。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听来自黑色效应播客网络（Black Effect Podcast Network）的《Drink Champs》。我认为我们都在意识到的、并且我知道这绝对是我的应对机制的一种巨大的逃避形式，那就是过度工作。
We live in a culture that celebrates hard work, glorifies people who put in extra shifts, who sleep less than they need. who are always really, really busy. What you don't see is that when somebody is a workaholic, or maybe even like a passionaholic, right, like maybe they're not working all the time, but they always have like a million hobbies and activities
我们生活在一个赞美努力工作、美化那些加班加点、睡眠时间少于所需、总是非常非常忙碌的人的文化中。你看不到的是，当一个人是工作狂，或者甚至是，比如狂热的工作狂，对吧，也许他们不是一直在工作，但他们总是有大约一百万个爱好和活动
or things that need their attention, this can be a way of physically cramming your life to be so emotionally full. There is no space left for the negative feelings to creep in. And that may, that is, not may, It is applauded. And actually, a lot of times people who are workaholics do see great success. They may do better professionally.
或者需要他们关注的事情，这可能是一种让你的生活在身体上塞满、在情感上变得极其充实的方式。这样就没有空间让负面情绪潜入了。这可能会，而且是，不是可能，它受到了赞赏。事实上，很多时候，工作狂确实取得了巨大的成功。他们在职业生涯中可能会做得更好。
But you'd be surprised. Like, their mental life, their social life, their emotional life probably suffers greatly, like deeply. It's also self-reinforcing. The more we avoid our feelings through work, the more we are driven to other negative behaviors once working hard loses its allure. There was a study from 2025 that followed like 1,200 full-time employees aged 25 to 65. And these participants filled out an online survey. They talked about that essentially assessed them for work addiction, emotional regulation deficits,
但你会感到惊讶。比如，他们的精神生活、社交生活、情感生活可能遭受了巨大的、深刻的痛苦。这也是自我强化的。我们通过工作逃避感觉的次数越多，一旦努力工作的吸引力消失，我们就越会被驱动去从事其他消极行为。有一项2025年的研究追踪了大约1200名25至65岁的全职员工。这些参与者填写了一项在线调查。他们谈到了本质上评估他们的工作成瘾、情绪调节缺陷、
addictive eating, physical functioning, like all these other coping mechanisms. And the study showed that workaholics had, A, depleted levels of emotional regulation over time, because again, their only coping mechanism is just to work more. But that also led to them being more likely to have addictive behaviors, like substance use, excessive drinking, eating as a coping mechanism, because it became the self-reinforcing cycle. It would, like, the more you work hard and the more you push, the less resources you have to take care of yourself,
成瘾性进食、身体机能，以及所有这些其他的应对机制。研究表明，工作狂，A，随着时间的推移，他们的情绪调节水平会耗尽，因为再次强调，他们唯一的应对机制就是做更多的工作。但这也会导致他们更有可能出现成瘾行为，比如物质使用、酗酒、将进食作为应对机制，因为它变成了这种自我强化的循环。这会，就像，你越是努力工作，你越是强迫自己，你用来照顾自己的资源就越少，
the less resources you have to hold yourself up. And so the more you then have to rely on, other behaviors to give you dopamine and other behaviors to make you feel whole. From a neuroscience perspective, which you guys know, we always have to offer a neuroscientific perspective. Many of these behaviors are rewarded, particularly through dopamine pathways. And they're rewarded in the short term, which makes them highly addictive, but stops us from actually resolving the underlying emotional state. Over time, what happens is something psychologists referred to as experiential avoidance. This is a really key concept from acceptance and commitment
你用来支撑自己的资源就越少，因此你随后就不得不越发依赖其他行为来给你提供多巴胺，依赖其他行为来让你感觉完整。从神经科学的角度来看，你们都知道，我们总是必须提供神经科学的视角。其中许多行为会受到奖励，特别是在多巴胺通路的奖赏下。而且它们在短期内会得到奖励，这使它们具有高度成瘾性，但阻止了我们真正解决潜在的情绪状态。随着时间的推移，发生的事情是心理学家所称的体验性回避。这是接纳承诺疗法（Acceptance and Commitment Therapy）中的一个核心概念。
therapy. And essentially, the more we try and suppress or outrun a feeling through whatever behavior is working, anything, the more persistent and intrusive it becomes. The emotion, yeah, it seemingly disappears. It's actually like in the background doing push-ups and getting stronger and stronger and stronger because it starts feeling more and more scary the more we avoid it. And we just keep delaying the moment that we will eventually have to face it, meaning that when we eventually do, we start to believe that all emotions when we encounter them must be difficult to manage because we only feel them at their most extreme point. Why we're really doing all of this is, like, because we're scared.
本质上，我们试图通过任何起作用的行为来压抑或逃避一种感觉，无论是哪种行为，这种感觉就会变得越发持久和具有侵入性。这种情绪，是的，它表面上消失了。实际上它就像是在后台做俯卧撑，变得越来越强、越来越强，因为我们越是逃避它，它就越让人感到害怕和恐惧。我们只是不断拖延最终不得不面对它的时刻，这意味着当我们最终面对时，我们开始相信所有情绪在遇到时都必定很难管理，因为我们只在它们最极端的时候才去感受它们。我们真正做这一切的原因是，因为我们害怕。
Like we're really scared that when the emotion finally hits us, it's going to take out the whole village and we're not going to be able to cope. Probably because, yeah, again, we're falling into this. pattern where we don't feel, we don't feel, and then when we do feel it's at like level 5,000. And we're so scared of excessively ruminating. We're so scared of hypervigilance taking over our lives. We don't know how to downregulate our feelings. We don't know how to stick, like just to sit with them. We don't know how to deal with them. And so it just gets worse. Again, not by choice, but through years of subconsciously teaching our minds that big feelings
就像我们真的很害怕，当这种情绪终于袭击我们时，它会摧毁整个村庄，而我们将无法应付。可能因为，是的，再次强调，我们陷入了这样一种模式：我们不去感受，我们不去感受，然后当我们去感受时，它就像是达到了5000级。我们非常害怕过度反刍。我们非常害怕过度警觉接管我们的生活。我们不知道如何下调我们的感觉。我们不知道如何坚持，就像只是和它们坐在一起。我们不知道如何处理它们，所以情况只会变得更糟。再次强调，这不是出于选择，而是通过多年来潜在地教导我们的头脑：巨大的感觉
are big disasters. Therefore, they should be avoided. Therefore, when we do feel them there, we don't have any healthy coping skills because the only way we cope is to just put up as many barriers as possible between us and the feeling. It's very sad. I think it's sad because it actually denies us the ability to enjoy a rich and meaningful life or to identify what needs to change or to work through things until they have a stable resolution. Also, we don't know ourselves. We don't know ourselves. If you don't know your emotions, your emotions are a reaction to your experiences. How can you know your experiences if you never are in touch with what you feel about them? So yeah, we miss out. And that's why we need to talk about, okay, what are we going to do here?
就是巨大的灾难。因此，它们应该被避免。因此，当我们确实感受到它们时，我们没有任何健康的应对技能，因为我们应对的唯一方式就是在我们和这种感觉之间建立尽可能多的屏障。这非常悲伤。我认为这很悲伤，因为它实际上剥夺了我们享受丰富而有意义的生活的能力，或者剥夺了我们识别需要改变什么或解决问题直到它们有一个稳定解决方案的能力。此外，我们不了解自己。我们不了解自己。如果你不了解你的情绪，你的情绪就是你体验的反应。如果你从来不接触你对它们的感受，你又怎么能了解你的体验呢？所以，是的，我们错过了。这就是为什么我们需要讨论，好吧，我们接下来要在这里做些什么？
Like, what is the path back to feeling our feelings without feeling like, my God, I want to know how many times I say feeling in this episode, but without feeling like they are going to completely run our lives? How do we actually actually? process our emotions. Something I've really come to learn recently is that our big emotions often like to disguise or hide themselves as other emotions that feel more temporary or easy to manage. And that's what we would call a presentation layer. That's the word I've heard use to describe it. If you want to learn how to process your emotions, you have to look for the clues and interrogate what is the immediate feeling and what is the deeper feeling?
比如，我们究竟该如何重新去感受情绪，却又不会觉得——天哪，我都不知道自己在这期节目里说了多少次“感觉”这个词——但又不会觉得它们会彻底掌控我们的生活？我们到底应该如何真正去处理自己的情绪？我最近真正学到的一点是，我们那些强烈的情绪往往喜欢伪装或隐藏成其他感觉，因为那些感觉看起来更短暂、也更容易掌控。这就是我们所谓的“表层防御层”。这是我听到用来形容这种现象的词。如果你想学会如何处理自己的情绪，你就必须寻找线索，去审视：什么是即时的感受，什么是更深层的感受？
Like, what is the feeling that comes first and what is the feeling that actually wants to be heard? In psychology, I think I've heard people refer to this as like a primary emotion, which is the original instinctual response. That's the real emotion, the sadness, the fear, the loneliness. And then again, the secondary emotion, and that's the one that comes in to protect us, like anger, irritability, numbness, even humor at times. I feel like humor is a massive coping mechanism. And again, this is a learned response. And it can often feel like the secondary emotion is the main emotion because it's a lot louder and it's a lot more visible. For example, like, I think anger is the best example of this, actually. Anger can feel a lot safer than admitting
比如，哪种感觉是先出现的，哪种感觉才是真正渴望被倾听的？在心理学中，我想我听人把这称为“初级情绪”，也就是最初的本能反应。这才是真实的情绪，悲伤、恐惧、孤独。然后是“次级情绪”，也就是那种跳出来保护我们的情绪，比如愤怒、易怒、麻木，有时甚至是幽默。我觉得幽默是一种巨大的应对机制。而且同样，这是一种后天习得的反应。而且你经常会觉得次级情绪就是主要情绪，因为它声音更大、也更明显。举个例子，我觉得愤怒其实就是最好的例子。比起承认
that you feel rejected. So when you've been like slided by a friend or criticized at work or ghosted or whatever. It's easier to just feel rage than to investigate why you feel rage, probably because you're scared about your value. You're scared about being lonely. This is bringing up past experiences of never feeling wanted or needed by anybody. And under all that anger is fear and under all that fear is a deeper fear of loss of losing people, of not feeling seen. Another example is jealousy. It's a lot easier to feel jealous of your partner's new girlfriend and to obsess over that jealousy than to admit that you actually feel a deep, deep sense of loss and sadness for the fact that, you know, the future you imagine with this person, it's not going to happen.
你感到被拒绝，愤怒会让你觉得安全得多。所以，当你被朋友冷落、在职场遭受批评、被无故疏远或遭遇类似事情时，去感受愤怒要比去探究你为什么会感到愤怒容易得多，这很可能是因为你对自己的价值感到不安。你害怕孤独。这会勾起你过去从未被任何人想要或需要的痛苦经历。而在所有愤怒的背后都是恐惧，在所有恐惧的背后则是更深层的恐惧——对失去的恐惧、对失去亲友的恐惧、对不被看见的恐惧。另一个例子是嫉妒。比起承认你内心其实对未来与这个人的想象将无法实现而感到深深的失落和悲伤，去嫉妒伴侣的新女友并对这种嫉妒念念不忘要容易得多。
Or your sadness at the years that you feel you've now wasted. Jealousy, anger, like the thing about our secondary emotions is that they often leave. to behaviors yet again that further detach us. Yes, through avoidance, but also through blame, through minimization, attacking other people, pushing other people away, like through jealousy, through anger, that sort of thing. So they actually don't do us any favors. You know what's a really great depiction of this? I just thought about this is Louis Thru's documentary about the Manosphere. I don't know if you've seen it. Great, by the way. You should watch it. But one thing that really jumps out to me about the whole red pill mannosphere movement and the men in this documentary
或者，对你觉得自己现在白白浪费了的那些岁月感到悲伤。嫉妒、愤怒，关于我们的次级情绪，有一点在于它们往往会导致那些让我们进一步疏离的行为。是的，通过逃避，但也通过责备、贬低、攻击他人、把别人推开，比如通过嫉妒、愤怒之类的方式。所以它们其实根本帮不上我们什么忙。你知道什么是对这种现象非常棒的描绘吗？我刚刚想到了路易·塞瑟克斯（Louis Theroux）关于“男性社群”（Manosphere）的纪录片。不知道你有没有看过。顺便说一句，非常棒。你们应该去看一看。但其中有一点真正触动我的，关于整个红丸男性社群运动以及这部纪录片中的那些男性
is that so many of them are just like deeply afraid and they have such deep childhood wounds that they don't want to address. I watched it a couple months ago so but from memory I think from memory I think only one of the men that he interviews doesn't have a complex relationship with their father or their mother or their families, only one of them. And there's like 10 people he interviews. And the anger and the control they feel towards women and sometimes towards themselves, I think just conceals a deeper fear of being lonely or of a loss of respect or social standing, a fear of not having control over one's own life or being seen as unworthy because they've gotten all this rejection from their parents, like not to psychoanalyze them, but I really do think
就是他们当中有那么多人都深感恐惧，他们有着极深的童年创伤，却根本不愿意去面对。我是几个月前看的，所以凭记忆来说，我记得在他采访的那些男性中，只有一个人与父亲、母亲或家庭的关系没有陷入复杂纠结，只有一个人。而他采访的人大概有10个。他们对女性、有时甚至对自己所感受到的愤怒和控制欲，我认为只是掩盖了更深层的恐惧：害怕孤独，害怕失去尊重或社会地位，害怕无法掌控自己的生活，或者因为从父母那里得到了所有这些拒绝而觉得自己不配被爱——倒不是要对他们进行心理分析，但我真的觉得
that's an explanation. The inability to correctly identify and accept these feelings of anxiety and fear is why this movement has gained so much notoriety and so much following amongst people who are similarly confused and they're like, cool, this is a great way that I don't have to ever feel any of that. I can just be mad and mean. This is something a psychologist friend of mine said to me a few weeks back, I was talking to her about this episode, she says, she said to me, so often our emotions pair up, like they come in pairs. There's the real emotion, and then there's, it's like bodyguard who we see and feel first. Like the thing we have to do is push past the bodyguard to see what's actually behind the bodyguard and see what the true emotion is, which often is quite a vulnerable
这就是解释。无法正确识别并接受这些焦虑和恐惧的情感，正是这场运动之所以获得如此高的知名度、并在同样感到迷茫的人群中赢得如此多追随者的原因，他们会觉得：“太好了，这是一个绝佳的方法，我再也不用去感受那些烂情绪了。我只要发火、使坏就行了。”这是我的一位心理学家朋友几周前对我说的话，当时我正跟她聊这期节目，她说，她对我说：我们的情绪经常会成双成对地出现，就像它们是结伴而来的。总有一种真实的情绪，然后还有它的“保镖”，也就是我们最先看到和感受到的那个。我们要做的事情，就是推开这个保镖，去看看保镖背后究竟是什么，看看真正的情绪是什么，而那通常是一种相当脆弱的情绪、相当无力的情绪，正因如此，它才需要保镖。
emotion and quite a weak emotion, hence why it needs the bodyguard. So I think part of processing our emotions is just initially asking ourselves, like, is this what I'm really feeling? It's like this anger, this jealousy, this outrage, this shame, is this really what I'm feeling or what am I trying to hide from here? What's the bodyguard covering up for? Another good way to do this is just quite simple. Expand your emotional vocabulary beyond just happy,
所以我觉得，处理情绪的一部分，起初只是问问自己：这真的是我的真实感受吗？就像这种愤怒、嫉妒、义愤、羞耻，这真的是我的真实感受，还是我在逃避什么？保镖到底在掩盖什么？另一个好方法其实很简单。扩展你的情感词汇量，不要仅仅局限于“高兴”、“难忘”、
sad, angry, even just fine. We all use these words a lot. I use these words a lot. But I bet you, quite often these words don't actually properly describe the emotional state that you are in. Giving yourself more words to work with to correctly identify what it is you're actually feeling is so helpful. Literally, you can go online right now, find a massive list, copy it into your notes up. When you're angry before bed, whenever you need it, find the word that you actually think best matches what you are sitting with rather than just, I'm not good or I have to be numb because I don't have the words. Psychologically, this is tied to a concept known as emotional granularity, which is your ability to identify and label emotions with precision.
“难过”、“生气”，甚至只是“还行”。我们所有人平时都经常用这些词。我也经常用。但我敢打赌，很多时候这些词根本无法准确描述你当时的情绪状态。给自己准备更多可以使用的词汇，来准确识别你到底在经历什么，这真的太有帮助了。真的，你现在就可以上网，找一大长串词单，把它复制到你的备忘录App里。当你睡前感到生气时，或者无论什么时候你需要时，去寻找那个你认为最贴合你当前心境的词，而不要仅仅说“我感觉不好”或者“我只能麻木，因为我词穷了”。从心理学上讲，这与一个被称为“情绪粒度”（emotional granularity）的概念息息相关，也就是你精确识别和标记情绪的能力。
Emotional granularity is actually, it's a really new term. I think it was only written about a couple years back by this woman called Lisa Feldman-Barrant, She wrote this book, How Emotions Are Made in like 2017. Don't quote me on that. It may have been earlier. It may have been later. And she basically realized, like, whilst writing this booklet, emotions fall across a four-point spectrum, how intense they are, and how aroused they
情绪粒度其实是一个非常新的术语。我想大概在几年前，一位名叫莉莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特（Lisa Feldman-Barrett）的女性才撰文写过它，她在2017年左右写了《情绪是如何诞生的》（How Emotions Are Made）这本书。别把我的话当成绝对权威。这可能更早，也可能更晚。她基本上意识到，在写这本小册子的过程中，情绪落在四个维度的光谱上：它们的强度有多大，以及它们让我们感到
make us feel. So how positive or negative they are and basically whether they make us feel like intense or quite slow and quite numb or quite, yeah. What's the opposite of intense? intense. I don't know, not intense. And her research shows that people with high emotional granularity, they are significantly better at regulating their emotions and being able to place their emotions because the brain responds differently when an experience is named accurately. So when you say, I feel bad, your mind has very little to work with because what does bad mean? Bad in what way?
多大程度的唤醒。也就是它们有多积极或有多消极，以及它们基本上是让我们感到情绪高涨，还是相当迟钝、相当麻木，或者，对。与“强烈”相反的是什么？不强烈。我不知道，就是不强烈。她的研究表明，具有高情绪粒度的人，在调节情绪和定位情绪方面要明显好得多，因为当人们能够准确地为一种体验命名时，大脑的反应是不同的。所以当你说“我感觉很糟糕”时，你的大脑其实没多少信息可供处理，因为“糟糕”是什么意思？哪种意义上的糟糕？
But when you identify that, you know, I feel disappointed, I feel rejected, I feel overstimulated, resentful, uncertain, you create clarity and when you are clear on something, you have control over it and the ability to process it. This is also connected to something called affect labeling where just simply putting feelings into words reduces, like they've shown this, it reduces activity in your amygdala, your fear response or your threat. at center, and it increases activity in areas responsible for reasoning and regulation. In other words, the more specific you are, the more words you have for your emotions, the less overwhelming your emotions tend to feel, meaning you're better able to process them. This is obviously harder for some people, especially for people on the spectrum, for example, they really struggle with this, but it can be taught.
但当你明确指出：“我知道，我感到失望、我感到被拒绝、我感到过度刺激、怨恨、不安，”你就创造了清晰感。而当你对某事有了清晰的认知时，你就拥有了对它的控制力以及处理它的能力。这还与一个叫做“情感标记”（affect labeling）的概念有关，即仅仅将感受用言语表达出来，就会减少——研究已经证实了这一点——减少你的杏仁核（即你的恐惧或威胁反应中心）的活动，并增加负责推理和调节区域的活动。换句话说，你越具体，你用来形容情绪的词汇越多，你的情绪往往就会显得越不那么具有压倒性，这意味着你更有能力去处理它们。这显然对某些人来说更难，特别是对自闭症谱系障碍（autism spectrum）的人来说，他们真的很挣扎，但这是可以被教导的。
Her research showed it can be taught, and having more language does help just the language. A fun fact also about emotional granularity, if you have high emotional granularity so you can label more emotions, this may seem very obvious, but you are also better able to read other people and you're better able to guess their emotions from very minor facial expressions. So also a good asset socially. When we have the label for what we're feeling, when we've pushed past the initial emotional guard, then we can actually start. like the processing part to all of this, which annoyingly actually begins, which is like kind of doing nothing, like just microdosing the feeling and learning to sit with it. Like processing emotions is incredibly boring work. The easiest way like to do it is just to sit with your emotion, but also just to give your emotion standing appointments of five minutes. This is a method
她的研究表明，这是可以被教导的，拥有更多的语言确实能起到帮助，仅仅是语言本身。关于情绪粒度还有一个有趣的冷知识：如果你拥有高的情绪粒度，也就是你能标记更多情绪，这可能看起来显而易见，但你也更有能力解读他人，能更好地通过极其微小的面部表情来猜出他们的情绪。所以在社交上这也是一项很好的资产。当我们有了对所感受事物的标签，当我们突破了最初的情感防线，我们就可以真正开始了。就像所有这些之中的处理阶段一样，令人烦恼的是，这个阶段实际上是从做一些事情开始的——也就是几乎什么都不做，比如给情绪进行“微剂量”体验，并学会与之共处。就像处理情绪是一项极其枯燥的工作。最简单的做法就是去感受你的情绪，但也给你的情绪安排固定的“预约”，比如五分钟。这是一个方法
that I heard about when I was at uni, but I recently saw it. displayed in an episode of shrinking, which, oh my God, best TV show on the planet right now. Love this show. In it, like, quick summary, because I'm like their number one fan. The, like, it shows this guy. He's like a therapist. He's also a dad. And his wife has died.
我在上大学时听说过，但我最近看到它在一个电视节目《诚实诊疗所》（Shrinking）的某一集中展现了出来，天哪，这简直是目前地球上最棒的电视节目。太爱这个节目了。在里面，简而言之，因为我是他们的头号粉丝，它展现了一个男人。他是一个治疗师。他也是个父亲。他的妻子去世了。
And he is the therapist. Like, he is the person that he kind of needs. But his life is falling apart. And he's basically trying to get through, you know, the grief of losing his wife and trying to take care of his daughter, whilst he's also trying to take care of people in, like, the worst moments of their lives. Super funny, Jason Siegel's in it, Harrison Ford's in it, a bunch of other great actors are in it.
他自己就是个治疗师。可以说，他就是那个最需要心理治疗的人。但他的生活正在分崩离析。他基本上是在努力熬过失去妻子的悲伤，努力照顾女儿，同时还要在人们生命中最糟糕的时刻去照顾他们。超级搞笑，里面有杰森·席格尔（Jason Segel）、哈里森·福特（Harrison Ford），还有一堆其他优秀的演员。
That's besides the point. They need to cut me a check for all the time I talk about this TV show. But in, there's this one episode where Harrison Ford's character is basically like, you don't have to, the options are don't feel the feeling or feel the feeling. you can just feel the feeling for five minutes at a time. Put on a five minute timer, put on a song, even that's going to last for the amount of time that you have. And for the duration of that song, for the duration of that five, ten minutes, just let it rip. Just let yourself feel every single piece aspect, depth of that emotion.
但这都不是重点。他们应该为我每次谈论这个电视节目付给我宣传费。但在其中一集里，哈里森·福特饰演的角色基本上说：你不用——选项要么是“不去感受情绪”，要么是“去感受情绪”。你大可以每次只感受五分钟的情绪。设定一个五分钟的计时器，放一首歌，甚至是一首刚好和你的时间一样长的歌。在那首歌的播放期间，在那五分钟、十分钟的期间里，彻底释放它。让自己去感受那种情绪的每一个碎片、每一个方面、每一个深度。
Let yourself feel furious. Let yourself feel sad and the sense of injustice. let yourself feel disappointed. Like you have five minutes to just let, just to open the gates, just to go. This technique may sound slightly like avoidance, because you know, you're only limiting how long you can feel the emotion for, but I think it addresses, again, the biggest reason we don't want to feel anything at all. We're worried that once we let the feeling in, like they're the captain now, we're never going to be free of it. But this exercise just continues to show you, like, I'm in control. I am the feeling and the feeling is me. And if I just give it space to have its
让自己感到愤怒。让自己感到悲伤和那种不公感。让自己感到失望。就像你有五分钟的时间去释放，去打开闸门，去宣泄。这个技巧听起来可能有点像逃避，因为你知道，你限制了自己感受情绪的时长，但我认为它再次解决了我们根本不想感受任何情绪的最大原因。我们担心一旦我们让情绪进来，就像它们现在成了船长，我们将永远无法摆脱它。但这个练习不断向你展示：我是掌控者。我就是情绪，情绪就是我。如果我只是给它空间去发泄、去经历它的时刻，它不会压倒我。如果我只是给它一个预约时间，并在那几秒、那几分钟里让自己去感受它，我就不必把整天、把一生的时间都花在压抑情绪上。好吧，我还有三个方法要分享，但我们确实需要再短暂休息一下。抱歉，我们马上回来。
tantrum, to have its moment, it's not going to overwhelm me. I don't have to spend my entire days, all my life suppressing an emotion if I just give it its appointment and let myself feel it in that second in those minutes. Okay, I have three more methods for you, but we do need to take one more short break. I'm sorry, we will be right back. is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio, Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts,
就像爱。你在心里能感受到它。iHeartRadio，加拿大排名第一的电台和播客流媒体应用，
including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists, like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you, anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada.
包括iHeart Pride Canada，你最喜爱的热门金曲和派对必听神曲，还有个性化及精选播放列表，比如重温昔日的骄傲岁月。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地，将骄傲带在身边。只需让你的智能音箱播放iHeart Pride Canada。
Stream us on your phone, or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me.
在手机上收听我们的节目，或立即登录 iHeartRadio.ca 收听。当时，感觉这一切仿佛永远不会结束。我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓了个半死。
That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. She's as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up.
那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以公平地说，这是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件吗？是的，长官。对儿童实施强奸和谋杀。这是最恶劣的罪行了。我想是的。大家醒醒吧。
I'm the one that saw the murder. take place by crevette and de pippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content,
我亲眼目睹了克里瓦克（Krivac）和德皮波（DePippo）实施的谋杀。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）毫无悔意，被判处最高刑期时也显得无动于衷。我说，我是无辜的。我会带着这个秘密进棺材。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼採石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。要想无广告收听《魔鬼採石场》并获取独家内容，
subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer
请在苹果播客上订阅 Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·柯特比（Hoda Kotb），播客《霍达·柯特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人们展开有意义的对话，比如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她是如何战胜严峻的健康挑战时。我曾经历过乳腺癌，
and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier Chichorito Hernandez.
然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌难关，那要艰难得多。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·柯特比的快乐101》。因为他们的全新球星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito Hernandez）。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist?
每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情感共处，从我出生起就是这样。而且我依然有这么多的问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消资格？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？
What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From everyday, unordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't an unorthodox. podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm here to pressur me but me will go to be able to connect. We are here to connect.
什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常到不凡，再到深刻与非凡。这不是一个墨守成规的播客。这里的一切都是随性、真实而真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深谈，脆弱在这里展露无遗。阴谋论最终被摆上桌面，目标和经验教训得以分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等我，我来这里是为了给我自己压力，但我们会能够产生连接。我们在这里就是为了建立连接。
The Chicharito. And Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human or IHard Radio, Apple Podcast, or whatever you get your podcast. Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else,
我是小豌豆（Chicharito）。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，我和 iHeart Radio 一起，将把平凡变得非凡，请持续关注。这真是个性格。哇。请在 iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。基思·吉安曼卡（Keith Gianmanca）看起来像个温和的郊区父亲，但私底下，他却变成了另一个人，
a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about How it could go wrong on what that might look like? No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success.
一个开启犯罪狂潮的伪装大师。当时，这听起来像是个疯狂的主意吗？听起来非常疯狂，但我当时感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你允许自己去想过事情可能会出错吗？会变成什么样？不，我不想去想那些不好的事。我当时只想吸引成功。
Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever, because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So giving your emotions a standing appointment definitely works, putting them in your diary. Great technique.
每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。这将会永远改变我和我家庭的动态，因为我现实中此前存在的一切现在都成了谎言。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深度卧底：顾家好男人》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。所以，给你的情绪安排固定的预约时间绝对管用，把它们写进你的日程表里。这真是个绝佳的技巧。
You know what also works? Just freaking, just screaming. Literally just screaming, crying, ripping something, punching something, dancing through something, chanting through something, running through something. whatever it is in a physical, expressive way. Let me explain that because, I know, like, how can you expressively run? You're probably thinking. Let me explain the whole principle behind this. What we're basically talking about is somatic release. Lots of us will know Vessel Vandelowc's, famous book, The Body Keeps the Score, Classic these days. It's a classic. If you haven't heard
你知道什么也管用吗？那就是发飙，大喊大叫。字面意义上的大喊大叫、痛哭流涕、撕碎东西、猛击东西、伴随音乐跳舞、大声吟唱、拼命奔跑。无论是哪种方式，只要是身体上的、宣泄式的方式都可以。让我解释一下，因为我知道，你们可能会想：“跑步怎么能算宣泄呢？”让我来解释一下这背后的整个原理。我们其实在谈论的是“躯体释放”（somatic release）。我们很多人都知道范塞尔·范德科克（Bessel van der Kolk）的名著《身体记得一切》（The Body Keeps the Score），如今这绝对是一本经典。这是一本经典之作。如果你没听说过
of it, or if you want a summary, it basically shows that trauma and emotion and pain register within our bodies on a cellular level. So your breakup, your self-doubt, your loneliness, your anger at your parents, your anxiety is as much physical as it is emotional. And the tensions or the tension of those emotions not being released impacts our muscles, impacts our limbs, impacts ourselves in a dangerous way. Somatic therapy is basically a way of processing that through kinetic movement and turning the tap back on and processing it through output and sensation and making like something, making a feeling tangible, putting it into a physical form when it normally sits in a very untouchable unconscious form. A really simple example of somatic
这本书，或者如果你想要个总结，它基本上表明了创伤、情绪和痛苦会在我们的细胞层面上记录在我们的体内。所以你的分手、你的自我怀疑、你的孤独、你对父母的愤怒、你的焦虑，既是身体上的，也是情绪上的。而这些未得到释放的情绪所产生的紧张感或张力，会以危险的方式影响我们的肌肉、我们的四肢、我们的细胞。躯体疗法基本上是通过动力学运动来处理这些情绪的一种方法，它重新扭开开关，通过输出和感觉来处理它，把某种东西、把一种感觉变得切实可感，当它通常处于一种非常不可触及的无意识状态时，把它转化为一种身体形态。躯体疗法的
healing is just shaking. I don't know if you have a dog, you'll see animals do this. After they experience a threat or they're stressed, they'll like shake. That's the nervous system. discharging excess energy. And humans have the same mechanism. Like we've just learnt to suppress it. We've just learnt to not look weird in front of people, even though our body needs something from us to process what we've been through. I know when I went through like a really, really sad time a couple of years back that, let's be real, like manifested in a lot of just like anger at the world. That is when I picked up boxing. And I would sometimes cry during those classes because I was so pent up and angry at the world in life. What was really below that anger was just like
一个非常简单的例子就是“抖动”。我不知道你有没有养狗，你会看到动物们会这样做。在经历威胁或感到压力之后，它们会像这样抖一抖。这就是神经系统在排出多余的能量。人类也有同样的机制。只是我们已经学会了压抑它。我们已经学会了在别人面前不要表现得那么奇怪，尽管我们的身体需要我们做点什么来处理我们经历过的事情。我知道当我在几年前经历一段非常非常悲伤的时期时——说实话——这表现为对世界的大量愤怒。正是在那个时候我开始练习拳击。我有时会在那些课程中哭泣，因为我对世界和生活积压了太多的怒火和愤怒。而隐藏在愤怒之下的其实只是
sadness and unfairness and helplessness. I had to get the anger out. That was like I had to get through that. That was the only way to access what was actually below the surface. And boxing helped me do that by releasing the semantic or the physical feeling. It's obviously a very intense example, but the same mechanism is at play for things like yoga as well. If you If you want to go down a hole, rabbit hole, look at the research on yoga and emotional processing and how many people will want to cry, scream, chant, heave, giggle during yoga classes and yoga practice because of how all these deep emotions are channeling through them physically, probably for the first time ever.
悲伤、不公和无助。我必须把愤怒发泄出来。这就好像我必须穿透那层愤怒。那是接触到表面之下的真实感受的唯一途径。而拳击通过释放躯体或身体上的感觉，帮助我做到了这一点。这显然是一个非常极端的例子，但同样的机制也在诸如瑜伽之类的事情中起作用。如果你想去深入钻研一番，去看看关于瑜伽和情绪处理的研究，看看有多少人在瑜伽课和瑜伽练习中会想要哭泣、尖叫、吟唱、呕吐、傻笑，因为所有这些深层情绪首次通过身体在他们体内奔涌，这可能是有史以来第一次。
The most famous paper on this is from 2014. It was a study on 64 women who had chronic treatment-resistant PTSD. So they tried a bunch of stuff. And they divided the group. They had half of them do these trauma-informed yoga sessions for like three years and half of them just do normal therapy. At the end of the study, almost 52% of the participants no longer met the criteria for PTSD compared to just 20% of the people who did therapy alone.
关于这个最著名的论文发表于2014年。那是一项针对64名患有慢性、难治性创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的女性的研究。所以她们尝试过各种方法。他们把这些人群分成了两组。其中一半的人参加了这些创伤知情（trauma-informed）的瑜伽课程，持续了大约三年，而另一半人只是接受常规治疗。在研究结束时，近52%的参与者不再符合PTSD的标准，而仅接受常规治疗的人中这一比例只有20%。
One in two of those people, their PTSD was treated. Now, obviously execute your judgment here. This isn't, and it's not the only method. an intervention for processing our feelings or for trauma, but you can't deny, like, the research is pretty powerful. Like, especially for a somatic approach, there's so much evidence that this channeling works. Any movement that you can, or that you have access to, move through the emotion, dance, hike, just, I don't know anything. It all functions on the same kind of plane and through the same mechanism of release. Another way to really process your own.
这些人中有一半人，他们的PTSD得到了治愈。现在，显然你要在这里做出自己的判断。这并不是说，它不是我们处理情绪或创伤的唯一干预手段。但你无法否认，这项研究相当有力。特别是对于躯体方法而言，有如此多的证据表明这种释放渠道是有效的。任何你可以进行的运动，或者你可以接触到的运动，去释放情绪，跳舞、远足，随便什么都行。它们都在同一种平面上运作，并通过相同的释放机制发挥作用。真正处理你自己的
emotions is to capture it through a different creative medium. Write it all down. Send yourself a voice note when you're like in the middle of the feeling. Journal just to see how your emotions evolve, make art, write poems, whatever it is. When you translate your emotions into words, into sound, imagery art, you are essentially converting something raw and implicit and hidden into something structured and explicit and visible. A lot of what processing our emotions really is is just being able to sit side by side within an emotion, let yourself feel it, understand why you are having it, and channeling it. And how have humans been doing that for thousands of years before you had podcasts like this one? Like through art, why do you think so many albums are breakup albums? Why do you
情绪的另一种方法是通过不同的创意媒介将其捕捉下来。把它全部写下来。当你正处于这种情绪之中时，给自己发一条语音备忘录。写日记只是为了看看你的情绪是如何演变的，创作艺术，写诗，无论是什么都可以。当你把情绪转化为文字、声音、意象或艺术时，你本质上是将某种原始的、内隐的、隐藏的东西，转化为某种结构化的、外显的、可见的东西。处理情绪的真正内涵，很大程度上其实就是能够与情绪并肩而坐，让自己去感受它，理解你为什么会有这种感受，并将其引导疏解。人类在拥有像这样的播客之前，几千年来一直是怎样做到的呢？比如通过艺术，你为什么认为那么多专辑都是“分手专辑”？你为什么
think so many movies are about grief? Or why do you think there's so much art about suffering and war and violence because it is the or one of the primary instinctual ways that we allow ourselves to feel as a species. Finally, if you really want to process your emotions and get to the solid core of why you are feeling what you are feeling when you are feeling it, oh my goodness, that was a million times, but if you really want that emotional clarity, that's going to mean, you know, you know yourself that's going to mean that you are in touch with yourself, please stop telling yourself that you're just not an emotions person. We are all feeling beings who think second in that order. Nobody is just not an emotions person. Something or someone has taught you that you're not. But
认为那么多电影都是关于悲伤的？或者为什么你认为有那么多关于苦难、战争和暴力的艺术？因为这是我们作为一个物种，让自己去感受的原始本能方式之一。最后，如果你真的想处理你的情绪，并找到你为什么会有这种感受、以及在产生这种感受时背后的坚实核心——天哪，刚才这句话我重复了一百万遍——但如果你真的想要那种情感清晰度，那将意味着，你知道的，这意味着你与自己保持着联系，请停止告诉自己你“只是一个不重感情的人”。我们所有人都是先有感受、后有思考的感性生灵。没有人“天生就不是个重感情的人”。是某些事或某个人教导你让你觉得自己不是。但在
underneath it all is like this deep, deep pool of feeling that will let you connect with so much more that life has to offer, even if it's hard at first. Sometimes the aim isn't to be constantly emotionally calm and balanced and in check. We want to feel intense grief. We want to feel like we want to feel rage when we witness injustice. We want to feel sadness when we witness rejection. Your body knows what's going on. And sometimes true emotional regulation is just being able to feel that and sit with
这一切的底层，是一汪深深的情感源泉，它能让你与生活所能提供的更多精彩建立连接，即使一开始会很艰难。有时，我们的目标并不是要时刻保持情绪上的平静、平衡和受控。我们希望去感受剧烈的悲伤。当我们目睹不公时，我们想要感受到愤怒。当我们遭遇拒绝时，我们想要感受到悲伤。你的身体知道发生了什么。有时，真正的情绪调节仅仅是能够去感受它，并与之共处，
and letting a whole range of emotions in so you have emo diversity. And letting that simply remind you, like, oh my God, this is evidence that I'm alive and I'm here and life hurts sometimes. But sometimes it also feels absolutely amazing and I cannot have one of those things without the other. I just think we're not aiming for perfection in our emotional processing. Again, we're aiming for that emo diversity. Can I look at my life and see that I'm feeling things deeply from all angles?
让各种各样的情绪进入你的内心，从而拥有情感的多样性（emo diversity）。让这一切简单地提醒你，天哪，这就是我活着的证据，我在这里，生活有时确实很痛。但有时它也感觉好极了，没有一种体验，你就无法拥有另一种体验。我只是觉得，我们在情绪处理上并不追求完美。再说一次，我们追求的是情感多样性。我能审视自己的生活，并看到我在全方位地深刻感受着各种事物吗？
because if you, it's just like one of the crappiest things about being human. Like there is nobody who feels absolutely happy all the time. And I often think that the people who are able to experience the deepest, most vibrant, like feelings of joy and feelings of elation and just like friendship and kinship and greatness are the ones who've also really been at the other end of the spectrum, right? Who've really been down in the dumps. Again, this is what we're talking about. Right now, I think a lot of us are sitting at this central frequency of emotion.
因为如果你——这就像是身为人类最糟糕的事情之一。没有人能做到绝对永远快乐。而且我经常认为，那些能够体验到最深沉、最充满活力、最极致的喜悦、狂喜、友情、亲情和伟大感的人，也正是那些真正经历过光谱另一端的人，对吧？那些真正跌落谷底的人。再次说明，这就是我们在讨论的。现在，我想我们很多人都处于这种中心频率的情绪中。
We feel every emotion, but we feel it at like 50%. Or we kind of only feel the emotions that influence us to a mid-range. We want to see and feel every single peak and troth. And again, to summarize, what that involves is understanding your coping mechanisms, what are the ways that you are detaching from your emotions through work, through escapism, through intellectualizing, and then also understanding your emotional bodyguards. For every deep emotion that feels painful or maybe shameful to feel, there's going to be a corresponding emotion that feels more appropriate to feel, like anger, like jealousy, like shame,
我们体验每一种情绪，但我们只发挥了大约50%的强度。或者我们某种程度上只体验那些将我们影响到中等程度的情绪。我们想要看到并感受到每一个山峰和低谷。再次总结一下，这涉及：了解你的应对机制，你通过工作、通过逃避、通过理智化来与情绪脱节的方式有哪些，然后还要了解你的情感“保镖”。对于每一种感觉痛苦或可能觉得有些羞耻的深层情绪，都会有一种与之相对应、觉得更“合适”去感受的情绪，比如愤怒、比如嫉妒、比如羞耻、
like nothing, like numbness. You process your emotions by being able to identify what that feeling after you. actually is, which is a distraction, and being able to move through that primary feeling, through semantic release, through art, through whatever means, so that you can really get to the deep core of, you know, why do I feel this way? And beyond an explanation, can I feel this way? Can I just let myself sit in the discomfort of being alive and know that sometimes that doesn't need an answer? I feel like this is the thing we've been getting to you all day. Like, what does it mean to process your emotions? It means.
比如虚无、比如麻木。你处理情绪的方式，在于能够识别出紧随其后的那种感觉实际上是什么——那是一种干扰；并且能够通过躯体释放、通过艺术、通过任何手段去经历那种初级感受，这样你才能真正触及核心：为什么我会这样？除了找到解释，我能去感受这种感觉吗？我能让自己安坐于活着的这种不适感中吗？并明白有时这并不需要一个答案。我觉得这就是我们一整天都在探讨的问题。究竟什么是处理情绪？这意味着：
being okay with not knowing why something is happening, but just knowing that you are feeling it and letting that be kind of part of your experience. That's my opinion. That's my opinion, at least. You can disagree. Maybe it means something else to you, but I think that's all I have time for. I need to take a, I feel like I've said the word feeling about 50 million times. So I need to, I need to take a breath after that. But I do hope that this episode has been informative. When I learned about like emotional bodyguards, my life changed. I genuinely was like, oh my God, I'm so much about who I am. As a person is explained, because I used to be so angry.
能够坦然接受“不知道某事发生的原因”，但仅仅知道你正在感受它，并让这种感受成为你体验的一部分。这就是我的看法。至少这是我的看法。你也可以不同意。也许对你来说这意味着别的什么，但我想我今天的时间就到这里了。我需要——我觉得我说了大概五千万次“感觉”这个词。所以我需要——在说了这么多之后，我需要喘口气。但我确实希望这期节目对大家有所启发。当我了解到“情感保镖”这个概念时，我的人生改变了。我真的觉得，天哪，关于我作为一个人的很多特质都有了解释，因为我以前总是那么暴躁。
And I was like, why am I such an angry, irritated person at times? I was like, oh, because that's like the only way I know how to feel anything. So maybe that's a realization you've had from this episode as well. I want to thank our researcher Lucy Davidson for her help, looking at some of these studies and research for this episode. As always, if you want more of the psychology of your 20s, you can go to our Instagram, you can go to our substack, and you can watch us on Netflix, wherever you are in the world. If you want to watch future episodes on your TV, on your laptop,
我当时就在想：为什么有时我是一个如此暴躁、易怒的人？然后我想：哦，因为那是当时我唯一知道的感受任何东西的方式。所以也许这也是你从这期节目中得到的顿悟。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）提供的帮助，她为这期节目查阅了其中的一些研究和资料。一如既往，如果你想了解更多关于20岁心理学的知识，你可以访问我们的Instagram、我们的Substack，无论你身在世界何处，都可以在网飞（Netflix）上收看我们的节目。如果你想在电视上、在笔记本电脑上观看未来的节目，
if you just want to see what it looks like that is available to you now worldwide, I'll leave a little link in the description. But again, I hope you enjoyed it. Thanks for visiting us here. Thanks for staying till the end. Till next time, be safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
如果你只是想看看它长什么样，现在世界各地都可以观看了。我会在简介里留下一个小链接。再次感谢，希望你们喜欢。感谢大家来到这里。感谢你们坚持听到最后。下次再见，注意安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. People, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief.
那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓了个半死。大家醒醒吧。我亲眼目睹了克里瓦克（Krivac）和德皮波（DePippo）实施的谋杀。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）毫无悔意，被判处最高刑期时也显得无动于衷。我说，我是无辜的。我会带着这个秘密进棺材。
Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, How to Coppe. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats.
在 iHeart Radio 应用的“骨谷喂养”（Bone Valley Feed）频道、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼採石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。快乐至关重要，却又总是难以捉摸。不过现在，有一个令人兴奋的全新方式来开启你迈向更快乐生活之旅：《快乐101》（Joy 101）。这是一档由我——霍达·柯特比（Hoda Kotb）主持的全新播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人至深的空中对话。
Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CBS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means. to be alive. I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio,
打开免费的 iHeart Radio 应用。搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。由CBS呈现的《霍达·柯特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情感共处，从我出生起就是这样。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是随性、真实而真诚的。这只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito Hernandez），请在 iHeart Radio、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit season two is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than they were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。这里有一件事本不该如此复杂：移除一座充满种族主义色彩的雕像。而这里还有另一件事本该容易得多：在原地树立一座新雕像。我是阿凯拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《叛逆精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季探讨的就是这两件事。当我看着这些雕像倒塌时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市里长大，那里对奴役者的致敬比对被奴役之人的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《叛逆精神》第二季。
Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我隐瞒他们是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我不得不做的事。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深度卧底：顾家好男人》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。这是一档 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。